สวัสดีค่ะครู
อ้อยสวัสดีค่ะครูชิและสวัสดีนักเรียนทุกๆ
คนนะคะสวัสดีทุกๆคนค่ะขอต้อนรับทุกคนนะคะ
เข้าสู่ห้องเรียน comprehensive ไยห้อง
เรียนภาษาไทยค่ะอืวันนี้วันนี้ครูครูชิ
และครูอ้อยมาพบกับนักเรียนวันเนี้ยวันที่
เท่าไหร่คะครูชิวันนี้วันพฤหัสบดีใช่มั้ย
คะอ่าวันพ
พฤหัสวันพฤหัสที่วันพฤหัสที่ที่เท่าไหร่
ครูชิ 2  11 ครูชิย่อแล้วกัน
21 อืนะคะเดือนกัยายน
กันยายนนะคะปี
พุทธศักราช
2566 ปีคริสตศักราช
2023 ค่ะแล้วคุชิเดือนนี้เป็นเดือนที่ 9
แล้วนะคะใช่ค่ะอเดือนที่ 9 นะคะเพราะ
ฉะนั้นวันนี้เนี่ยครูชิกับครูอ้อยมาเจอ
กันวันพฤหัสสดีวันที่ 21 เดือนกันยายน
พุทธศักราช
2566 คริสตศักราช
2023 ค่ะครูอ้อยคุณชิสบายดีใช่มั้ยคะ
สบายดีค่ะครูอ้อยล่ะคะสบายดีมยสบายดีค่ะ
ขอบคุณมาก
อืก็วันเนี้ยครูชิเเนี่ยไปดูเอ่อครูชิไป
ดู YouTube อ่ะแล้วครูชิเนี่ยได้ยินคน
ญี่ปุ่นเนี่ยพูดถึงว่าเค้าเนี่ยมาอยู่
ประเทศไทยค่ะครูอ้อยแล้วอยู่ประเทศไทย
เนี่ยนานแล้วเขาก็มีของมีบางอย่างที่ใน
ประเทศไทยที่เเชอบแล้วเอยากเวลากลับไปที่
ญี่ปุ่นน่ะเอยากให้ที่ญี่ปุ่นมีแบบประเทศ
ไทยอ่ะอยากให้ที่ญี่ปุ่นมีเหมือนประเทศ
ไทยอื้อหือพครูอ้้อยอยากรู้แล้วเคเคชอบ
อะไรของเรานะเา้าบอกว่าตอนที่เาอยู่
ประเทศไทยอ่ะแล้วก็มีเพื่อนๆเยอะเนี่ย
เวลามีปาร์ตี้ใช่มั้ยเพื่อนๆก็โทรศัพท์
แล้วก็สั่งหมูกระทะมากินที่บ้าน
ได้หมูกระทะออใช่คนไทยเนี่ยนอกจากไปกิน
ที่ร้านเนี่ยเราโทรสั่งเพะเอาทั้งเตาทั้ง
กระทะทั้งเครื่องทุกอย่างมาให้เราหมดเลย
ชิใช่ค่ะแล้วแล้วเพื่อนคนญี่ปุ่นก็บอกว่า
เค้าอ่ะอยากให้มีแบบนี้ในประเทศญี่ปุ่น
จังพอเวลากลับไปที่ญี่ปุ่นน่ะสิ่งที่เขา
คิดถึงมาก
ก็คือหมูกระทะโอถ้าเรื่องนี้ครูชิครูอ้อย
อ่ะมี
ประสบการณ์ลูกสาวครูอ้อยเรียนที่
เชียงใหม่หลายปีแล้วแหละแล้วก็มีนักเรียน
แลกแลกเปลี่ยนจากญี่ปุ่นมาแล้วพอเคเรียน
ครบปีเต้องกลับเคต้องกลับญี่ปุ่นไงเค้า
ให้ลูกสาวครูอ้อยอ่ะหาซื้อกระทะกระทะทำ
หมูกระทะอ่ะถือกลับญี่ปุ่นครูชิโอ้โหครู
อ้อยอย่างเงี้ยก็แสดงว่าไม่ใช่แบบมีคนนี้
คนเดียวนะที่ชอบเอ่อหมูกระทะใช่มั้ยมี
หลายๆคนเนี่ยชอบหมูกระทะใช่คุชิแล้วร้าน
หมูกระทะในประเทศไทยเนี่ยมีทุกจังหวัดมี
เยอะมาก
ๆอืคือเที่ยงคืนเนี่ยกูชิยังโทรสั่งได้
ได้อ่ะยังไปกินที่ร้านได้
อ่ะครูชิเข้าใจและทำไมคนญี่ปุ่นถึงแบบชอบ
คืออย่างนักเรียนครูชิเเนี่ยครูชิสอนอยู่
โรงเรียนนานาชาติก็จะมี
เอ่อที่ที่โรงเรียนน่ะก็จะมีหอพักนะแล้ว
ครูชี้เนี่ยอยู่ที่หอพักเด็กๆเนี่ยก็จะ
โทรศัพท์สั่งหมูกระทะมาเหมือนกันเอ้อเค้า
เองก็จะบอกว่าร้านหมูกระทะบางทีไม่มีเอ่อ
ไม่มีไส้กรอกนะคะไม่มีอะไรที่เา้าชอบกิน
เาจะซื้อมาด้วยแล้วก็มาใส่ในหมูกระทะใช่
มั้ยใส่ได้ทุกอย่างเนาคุณชิใช่คือสั่งมา
เนี่ยจะสั่งเนื้อหมูมาใช่มั้ยอาจจะสั่ง
ข้างในเช่นตับอ่านะตับของหมูอ่ะนะคะหรือ
ไส้ไส้ไสที่เป็นเส้นยาวๆใช่มยเอ่อคนไทยก็
กินไงเขาก็จะสั่งมามีหมูมีตับมีไส้แล้วก็
มีผักที่เป็นเซตของเขาแต่เขาคก็จะไปซื้อ
แบบเอ่อเป็นเอ่อเป็นอะไรล่ะเหมือนกับเป็น
หมู 3 ชั้นยาวๆใช่มเบคอนเหรออ้าเบคอนอื
แล้วเบคอนแบบสไลด์บางๆบางๆบางๆเขาบอกว่า
ถ้าสั่งที่ร้านน่ะนิดหน่อย
ถ้าไปซื้อเบคอนมาแล้วก็เอาน้ำซุปของร้าน
เนี่ยเขาจะกินได้เยอะๆออแล้วเขาอยากจะ
เพิ่มไส้กรอกเขาก็ซื้อเข้ามาใส่ได้อยากจะ
ใส่ปูอัดก็ใส่ได้บางคนไปซื้อกุ้งมาด้วยอื
กุ้งสดก็มาใส่ได้
มันสะดวกสบายูชิเขาบอกว่าที่โทรสั่งเนี่ย
อยากได้น้ำซุปอใช่ๆเพราะน้ำซุปหมูกระทะจะ
อร่อยอืออืแล้วก็มีผักมันได้ครบนะคูชิได้
ทั้งผักได้ทั้งเนื้อสัตว์อือใช่แล้วก็
อยากได้น้ำ
จิ้มถูกมั้ยน้ำจิ้มหมูกระทะอ่ะเพราะว่าทำ
เองอ่ะก็จะไม่เหมือนที่ร้านไงใช่แล้วโช
สั่งเนี่ยสะดวกอะไรมั้ยครูชิที่ครูอ้อย
ชอบมากคือเวลาเ้ามาส่งเรากินิเสร็จแล้ว
เนี่ยเราไม่ต้อง
ล้างเราไม่ต้องล้างกระทะไ้ล้างกระทะหมู
อ่ะเราก็วางเอาไว้แล้วก็เราแค่ล้างจานที่
เรากินเฉยๆชิอื้อหือแล้วพนักงานน่ะซักวัน
รุ่งขึ้นนะเค้าก็จะมาเก็บกระทะกับร้านอือ
ฮึมันก็สะดวกนะคูชิเราไม่ต้องซื้อกระทะ
ด้วย
อื้อหือแล้วแล้วไอ้ไอไอแบบเอ่อที่ที่เรา
พูดถึงอ่ะนะไอ้กระทะหมูกระทะไม่รู้นัก
เรียนของของเราเนี่ยรู้จักมั้ยออครูชิมี
รูปโชว์นักเรียนมั้ยครูชิขอวาดแล้วกันเนจ
ๆมันจะเป็นแบบนี้เตาอ่ะนะเอ่อเออกระทะอ่ะ
มันจะแล้วก็จะมีรูๆอยู่ข้างบนใช่มั้ยอ่า
สำหรับเวลาที่เราจะย่างอะไรแบบเนี้ยย่าง
หมูใช่มั้ยวางไว้ข้างบนนะกระทะมันจะเป็น
รูๆแบบนี้นะข้างบนเสร็จแล้วเนี่ยก็จะมี
แบบลึกๆอยู่รอบๆเนี่ยตรงเนี้ยมันเป็นน้ำ
ซุปถูกมั้อใช่ใส่ใส่น้ำซุปในนี้ได้นะมัน
จะแบบลึกๆไปอย่างงี้อ่าเพราะฉะนั้นตรง
เนี้ยมันจะเป็นน้ำซุปอือที่เค้าจะชอบใช่
มั้ยแล้วก็มีหูกระทะตรงนี้อ่าอือเอเป็น
ลักษณะแบบนี้คะนักเรียนถึงเวลากินเนี่ยเา
เราเอาเนื้อวางไว้บนกระทะส่วนนูนน่ะนะอื
น้ำของเนื้อมันก็จะลงมาที่น้ำซุปใช่ตรง
นี้นะออกรสชาติหวานแบบอร่อยอืเสร็จแล้ว
เราก็จะแบบเอาเนื้อใช่มั้ยวางอยู่ที่
เนี่ยย่างไปมันก็จะสุก
นี่นี่คือหมูกระทะเออแล้วเาก็จะมีเต่าใช่
มั้ยใช่
อ่า
เนี่ยบางบ้านมีตัวกระทะเอาไว้เลยครูชิบาง
บ้านอย่างบ้านครูอ้อยก็มีแหมครูอ้อยไม่
ได้ลงไปหยิบให้ดูอย่างบ้าครูอ้อยมีแบบแบบ
ถ้าลูกๆนัดเพื่อนๆมาเนี่ยเราก็ทำกินกัน
ได้เลยที่บ้าน
อืมันก็สะดวกอืทีเนี้ยเค้าบอกว่าเวลาที่
อารมณ์ไม่ดีอ่ะหงุดหงิดไม่สบายใจนะเค้า
บอกว่าโทรศัพท์สั่งหมูกระทะแล้วพอกินหมู
กระทะเนี่ยอารมณ์จะดีเลยค่ะมันเพลินค่ะ
เราก็ต้องคอยแบบดูแล้วก็พริกหมูใช่มั้ยมี
อืมันไม่ต้องคิดเรื่องที่ทำให้กลุ้มใจไง
คูชิมันใจจดใจจ่ออยู่กับหมูที่เราย่าง
อยู่แล้วคนญี่ปุ่นคนนี้บอกว่าหมูกระทะ
เนี่ยเป็นอะไรที่เยียวยาสำหรับเวลาที่
เสียใจไม่สบายใจเ้าบอกว่าถ้ามีที่ญี่ปุ่น
นะแบบมันแบบสุดยอดอ่ะอือนี่คือสิ่งที่คน
ญี่ปุ่นอยากให้มีที่นั่นใช่มยอืใ่อ่ะอยาก
ให้มีมากๆนะคะอย่างที่ 2 ค่ะที่แบบเขาค
อยู่เมืองไทยแล้วเรู้สึกแบบว่าแรกๆก็รู้
สึกแปลกนะแต่พออยู่ไปอยู่มาก็รู้สึกแบบ
ว่าเออมันสะดวกสบายเนเวลาจะไปไหนเนี่ย
แล้วก็มีมอเตอร์ไซค์ค่ะมอเตอร์ไซค์รับ
จ้างออเ้าจะมีทุกซอยเนในกรุงเทพฯเนี่ยซอย
อ่ะที่แบบเข้าไปลึกๆอ่ะจะมีมอเตอร์ไซค์
รับจ้างเนี่ยจอดอยู่ปาก
ซอยแล้วคนที่เดินหรืออาศัยอยู่ในซอยก็จะ
ต้องนั่งมอเตอร์ไซค์เข้าไปคือเมืองไทยมัน
ร้อนน่ะเวลาเดินเนาะแล้วเดินไกลเดินกัน
ไม่ค่อยเก่งนะแต่คนญี่ปุ่นเดินเก่งนะูชิ
เขาจะชอบมอเตอร์ไซค์รับจ้างเหรอคะคน
ญี่ปุ่นบอกว่าคนเนี้ยเค้าบอกว่าเค้าอยู่
เมืองไทยอ่ะมันสะดวกสบายไงจะเข้าซอยไม่
ต้องเดินเองใช่มั้ยแล้วมอเตอร์ไซค์ก็ไม่
แพง 10 บาท 20 บาทก็เข้าซอยไปโอหบางทีมัน
ลึกมากไงอืพอไปกลับไปอยู่ญี่ปุ่นน่ะครู
อ้อยเ้าบอกว่าบางบางทีเข้าไปอ่ะซอยลึกมาก
เลยอ่ะแต่คนญี่ปุ่นไม่มีมอเตอร์ไซค์รับ
จ้างไงก็เลยต้องเดินค่ะเบอกเเดินนะเคก็
คิดถึงเมืองไทยมากอยากให้ญี่ปุ่นเนี่ยมี
มอเตอร์ไซค์รับจ้างแบบประเทศไทยจังเลย
เวลาที่ต้องเดินเข้าซอยเองอ่ะแย่แล้วูชิ
ธรรมดาเ่อญี่ปุ่นเยเป็นเป็นคนที่ขึ้นชื่อ
ว่าเดินเก่งที่
สุดติดนิสัยไม่ชอบเดินเหมือนคนไทยะเอ้า
อาจจะแบบว่าคืออยู่ญี่ปุ่นใช่มยถูกฝึกมา
ให้เดินอย่างงั้นเรื่อยๆไงก็เลยคิดว่าการ
เดินก็ก็ดีจริงๆก็เป็นดีกับร่างกายเนอะเอ
แขงแงเนาะอใช่ใช่อ่าแต่บางทีรีบไงต้องรีบ
ไปเพราะบางครั้ง
เนี่ยใช่มอเตอร์ไซค์ไม่ได้วิ่งแค่ในซอยไง
ูชิอื้อหือเราสามารถจ้างวิ่งไปที่อื่นได้
ด้วยอืเค้าก็ไม่ต้องเดินรถติดก็ใช้
มอเตอร์ไซค์ได้อื้อหืออือเห็นมเ้าเลยบอก
โอ้โหอันเนี้ยคิดถึงเมืองไทยมากอยากให้มี
มอเตอร์ไซค์รับจ้างที่ญี่ปุ่นจังเลย
อ่ะโอ้โหอยากอยากเอามอเตอร์ไซค์รับจ้าง
ที่ประเทศไทยอ่ะมาอยู่
ญี่ปุ่นนะคคิดถึงมากนะคะสบายใช่สะดวก
สะดวกสบายเร็วใช่อืเห็นม
อ่าต่อไปสิ่งที่เขาอยากแล้วก็คิดถึงว่า
ตอนที่เขากลับไปอยู่ญี่ปุ่นแล้วก็คิดถึง
ประเทศไทยมากๆเขาบอกว่าที่ถนน
น่ะในประเทศไทยเนี่ยจะมีอาหารที่แบบมีคน
เนี่ยเข็นมาค่ะแล้วก็มาขายนะคะโดยเฉพาะ
หมูปิ้งอ่ะนั่นครูอ้อยบอกครูชิพูดถึงครู
อ้อยคิดเลยอ๋อข้าวเหนียวหมูปิ้งข้าว
เหนียวส้ม
ตำรสเข็นเนาะเยอะใช่ก็จะมีเตาใช่มยเจะเอา
หมูเยเสียบมาแล้วก็ปิ้งปิ้งปิ้งปิ้งมันดู
ง่ายๆธรรมดานะแต่หลายๆคนกินแล้วก็บอก
โอ้โหมันอร่อยมันแบบ
มันๆหวานๆเค็มๆอแล้วกินกับข้าวเหนียวเนาะ
มันเข้ากัน
มากใช่แล้วเบอกนะตอนที่มาอยู่เมืองไทยอ่ะ
แล้วตอนที่เา้าจะออกไปข้างนอกตอนเช้าอ่ะ
เขาก็จะเจอร้านที่มีรถเข็นแบบเนี้ยแล้วก็
มีหมู่ปิ้งเขาก็จะซื้อเลยค่ะหมูปิ้ง 3
ไม้ข้าวเหนียว 1 ไม้ก็รู้สึกอิ่มได้มื
เช้าใช่อืเขาบอกถ้าวันไหนหิวเขาก็จะเอา
หมูปิ้ง
5 ข้าวเหนียว 2
โอ้โหอันนี้อิ่มถึงกลางวันอิ่มมากแล้วก็
ไม่แพงโหแต่คูชิเนี่ยอันเนี้ยกูอ้้อยว่า
ไม่ใช่แค่ญี่ปุ่นหรอกคนต่างชาติหลายๆ
ประเทศก็ชอบเพราะประเทศไทยเนี่ยหาซื้อของ
กินง่าย
มากคือ 22:00 น 23:00 นเที่ยงคเราออกจาก
บ้านก็ยังมีของกินข้างทางเราไม่ต้องไปไกล
อ่ะคือเราเดินออกไปเนี่ยตามริมถนนน่ะมัน
มีของกินที่ก็เค้าเรียกสตีท Food เหมือน
กันมยสุชิอื้อใช่คือจะมีอาหารทุกอย่าง
เนาะอยู่ข้างทางก๋วยเตี๋ยวก็
มีข้าวก็มีน้ำก็มีขนมก็มีทุกอย่างแล้ว
แล้วคนญี่ปุ่นบอกว่าที่เขาชอบมากที่สุด
ตอนมาอยู่ประเทศไทยอ่ะก็คือที่มีรสเข็นนะ
แล้วทุกอย่างจะมีผลไม้อนะคะมี
แตงโมมีมะม่วงสีเขียวที่แบบกินแล้ว
เปรี้ยวๆมันๆมีฝรั่งนะคะมีชมพู่มี
แคนตาลูปมีสับปะรสก็บอกโอ้โหอันนี้ก็ชอบ
มากชอบมากที่สุดค่ะครูอ้อยอ่าเพราะมันมี
ให้เลือกเยอะเนาะมีหลายชนิดแล้วมันเย็นๆ
ด้วยนะเแช่น้ำแข็งมาเย็นๆด้วยนะพอมันร้อน
ๆกินก็จะชื่นใจอืแล้วเค้าบอกยังไงหมั้ย
เขาบอกตอนครั้งแรกที่เขาเห็นรถเข็นเนี่ย
แล้วก็มีผลไม้มันจะมีเหมือนกระจกเป็นช่อง
ๆใช่มั้ยแล้วก็ทุกอย่างก็หั่นไว้เรียบ
ร้อยละพอถึงเวลาเราสั่งเอาอะไรดีแตงโม
ชิ้นละ 20 ใช่มั้ยก็จะมีคนแบบเค้าบอกว่า
เค้าก็จะปาดปรื๊ดแตงโมแล้วก็ตึดๆๆๆๆๆเค
บอกสับเร็วมากอะไรที่
แบบแล้วเบอกก็ชอบอีกอย่างค่ะก็คือเวลาที่
ซื้อแอปเปิ้ลน่ะแล้วพ่อค้า
ก็เอามีดเนี่ยสับแล้ว
ก็ไม่เคยเห็นที่
ญี่ปุ่นที่ญี่ปุ่นเนี่ยที่ญี่ปุ่นเขาจะ
เอาไม้เสียบนะครูอ้อยแล้วก็เอาหัหั่นตาม
ไม้มันก็จะเหลือเป็นไม้จิ้มอ๋ออันอันนี้
ไม่ต้องใช้ไม่ต้องใช้ไม้เสียบค่ะูชิเอา
ไว้ที่มือแล้วก็ชึบๆึบๆอย่างงี้เลยโอห
เสียวมือเราเรียกว่าเฉาะนะ
เฉาะใช่จะมีฝรั่งมะม่วงแอปเปิ้ลที่ทำได้
เนาะทำได้ทุกอย่างคนทำเร็วมาก
อ่ะบอกว่าเค้าแบบตกใจมากไม่เคยเห็นใน
ญี่ปุ่นแล้วก็รู้สึกแบบโอ้โหชอบมากเลยอ่ะ
แล้วผลไม้ไม่แพง 20 บาท 20 บาท 20 บาท
เลือกกินอะไรก็ได้ชิ้นละ 20 บาทอ๋อได้
หลายอย่างด้วยใช่เบอกโอหอันเนี้ยเป็นของ
ชอบมากไม่คุณชิมันไม่ใช่มีผลไม้มันมีน้ำ
จิ้มด้วยไงมันมีตัวจิ้มด้วยคืออย่างแบบ
พริกกับเกลือยอย่างเงี้ยที่เอาเอ่อมะม่วง
จิ้มลงไปแล้วก็กินเพราะบางทีมะม่วงมัน
เปรี้ยวไงก็จิ้มกินแล้วมันก็แบบมันลดความ
เปรี้ยวมันก็จะอร่อยขึ้นออ่ามันแล้วก็มี
จิ้มหลาย
ชนิดเห็นมั้อันเนี้ยเค้าบอกว่าโอ๊ยอยากๆๆ
อยากให้มีรสเข็นที่ขายอาหารที่ถนนน่ะเวลา
เดินไปที่ถนนหิวเนี่ยก็ซื้อกินได้อยากให้
ไปอยู่ประเทศญี่ปุ่นจัง
ญี่ปุ่นอยากให้ที่ญี่ปุ่นมีจังเลยนะคะ
อืแล้วก็มีอีกค่ะที่อยากให้ที่ญี่ปุ่นมี
ค่ะคืออะไรคะเวลามาประเทศไทยจะมีถนนที่
ไม่มีรถค่ะเค้าจะปิดเป็นเวลาแล้วก็ให้คน
เยเดินแล้วที่ถนนเนี่ยเมื่อกก่อนที่จะ
เป็นถนนแล้วก็ให้คนเดินเนี่ยตอนเช้าเนี่ย
ยังมีรถขับมีรถวิ่งอยู่นะพอตกตอนเย็น
เนี่ยจะไม่มีรถอ๋อเปิดถนนเลยห้ามรถเข้ามา
แล้วให้แม่ค้าเข็นรถเข็นเข้าไปขายของกิน
ขายเสื้อผ้าขายทุกอย่างอยู่ในนั้นเขา
เรียกถนนคนเดินคูชิเาบอกเชอบมากเวลาไปถนน
คนเดินเขาบอกมันสนุกสนุกมีทั้งของกินเยอะ
ไปหมดเลยแล้วก็มีของที่เราอยากจะซื้อกลับ
บ้านได้ด้วยนะอืคูชิแล้วประเทศไทยเนี่ยมี
เกือบทุกจังหวัดเลยถนนคนเดินเนี่ยจะมี
เฉพาะศุกร์เสาร์อาทิตย์จะมีเกือบทุก
จังหวัดเวลาเราไปเที่ยวต่างจังหวัดเราก็
จะหาว่าจะจังหวัดเนี้ยถนนคนเดินอยู่ตรง
ไหนแล้วเราก็จะไปทุกครั้งคุชิเพราะเรา
สามารถหาซื้อของของประจำจังหวัดนั้นเสื้อ
ผ้าหรือของกินที่จังหวัดนั้นเนี่ยดังอ่ะ
เป็นขึ้นชื่อของจังหวัดนั้นน่ะเราสามารถ
หาที่นี่ได้เลย
อาฮะอย่างอะไรอ่ะเอ่อสมมุติว่าเราไป
เชียงใหม่ใช่มยก็จะมีเสื้อผ้าแบบคน
เชียงใหม่ขายใช่ใช่แล้วก็อยู่ที่ถนนคน
เดินโอ๊อย่าว่าแต่คนญี่ปุ่นอย่าว่าแต่ชาว
ต่างชาติค่ะคนไทยเนี่ยก็ชอบค่ะใช่คนไทยก็
ชอบเวลาเราไม่แพงนะอของไม่แพงนะอือแล้ว
เวลาเราไปเที่ยวเชียงใหมู่ชิ
ูชิบอกว่าเวลาูชิไปเที่ยวเชียงใหมู่ชิก็
จะไปไปเหมือนกันไปค่ะไปถนนคนเดินที่
เชียงใหม่ค่ะโอ้โหแล้วตอนนี้ถนนคนเดิน
เชียงใหม่เนี่ยเดินได้ไกลขึ้นน่ะนะคะแล้ว
มี 2 วัน
ด้วยมี 2 แห่งด้วย
เออคือเมื่อก่อนเนี่ยถนนคนเดินไม่ยาวมาก
นะคอยู่ประมาณ 1 ซอยต่อมาก็ 2 ซอย 3 ซอย
คือมันจะมีแบบถนนที่แบบตัดกันแบบนี้ใช่มย
ตอนเถนนเนี่ยมันยาวจนแบบเนี่ยตัดเป็นแบบ
3-4 ล็อคอ่ะใช่ใช่มยเมื่อก่อนเยล็อค
เดียวเท่านั้นนะปิดหัวปิดท้ายตอนนี้มี 1
ล็อค 2 ล็อค 3 ล็อค 4 ล็อคยาว
มากเยอะร้านก็เยอะมากอือคือเวลาไปเดินถนน
คนเดินเนี่ยโอ้โหจะมีแบบถุงหิ้วมาเต็มเลย
อ่ะใช่ถึงเราก็จะแบบเหมือนกับมีของกิน
ด้วยเอากลับมาโรงแรมใช่มั้ยแล้วก็มากิน
กันแล้วก็มีของแบบเสื้อผ้าของคนเชียงให
ของภาคเหนือของคนเชียงใหม่ใส่มีเครื่อง
ประดับด้วยนะบางทีก็มีสร้อยเงินมีต่างหู
ถ้าเราชอบเนาะอืแล้วเดินๆก็มีเสียงเพลง
ด้วยบางครั้งเด็กๆก็มาเล่นมาเล่นดนตรี
เนาะเปิดหมวกใชเออมีการแสดงเล็กๆน้อยๆเออ
มันมันครบถ้วนอยู่ในนั้นน่ะเดเดินแล้วก็
สนุกแล้วบางที่เนี่ยก็มีวาดรูปใช่ใช่มั้ย
มีวาดรูปเนี่ยเราก็ไปนั่งแล้วให้เขาวาด
รูปให้ 100 บาทโอได้รูป 100 บาทนั่งไม่
กี่นาทีนะใช่ 10 นาทีได้รูปมาแล้วอ่ะเรา
ก็โอ้โหเก็บเอาไว้อันนี้เป็นถนนคนเดิน
เชียงใหม่อันนี้ถนนคนเดินพัทยาอันนี้ถนน
คนเดินภูเก็ตออไปเที่ยวมีทุกจังหวัดอือ
แล้วก็แบบคนไทยก็ยังชอบเพราะมันสนุกไงอือ
ไปที่เดียว
เนี่ยได้ทั้งของที่ซื้อกลับบ้านได้ทั้ง
เสื้อผ้าที่เราชอบบางทีได้หมวกได้กระเป๋า
อือได้สร้อยได้สร้อยคลออืได้อาหารกินโอโห
ครบในถนนคนเดินมีทุกอย่างใช่อ่ะคนญี่ปุ่น
คนนี้ก็เลยบอกโอ้โหอยากอยากให้ญี่ปุ่นมี
ถนนคนเดินแต่ละชนิดเนี่ยที่เขาบอกมาเนี่ย
4 ข้อทีู่ชี่บอกมาเนี่ยไม่ว่าจะเป็นหมู
กระทะมอเตอร์ไซค์รับจ้างหน้าปากซอยแล้วก็
อะไรนะรถเข็นขายของข้างทางถนนคนเดิน 4
อย่างเนี้ยคนไทยก็
คือมันเป็นสิ่งที่คนไทยก็ขาดไม่ได้เหมือน
กันนะูชิใช่ค่ะครูอ้อยกูก็เห็นมยว่ามัน
สะดวกแล้วก็สบายนะคะสมมุติเราไปเอ่อไปไป
เที่ยวนะเรานอนโรงแรมใช่มั้ยแต่เราอ่ะไม่
ได้ตื่นเวลาที่อาหารของโรงแรมอ่ะตื่นสาย
ใช่มั้ยเราออกมาที่ถนนเนี่ยเราก็เจออาหาร
ขายแล้วอ่ะใช่ข้างทางจะมีอย่างน้อยอ่ะ
ข้าวเหนียวหมูปิ้งอืเป็นอะไรที่แบบอเดิน
ไปแล้วก็อิ่มท้องอร่อยนอกจากข้าวเหนียว
หมูปุ้งมันมีข้าวเหนียวหมูฝอยหมูเค็ม
สารพัดเลยนะกูชิที่เราจะกินกับข้าวเหนียว
แล้วให้อิ่มท้องได้ในมื้อเช้าอือย่างตอน
ที่ครูชิเนี่ยไปเที่ยวที่ชะอำมีทะเลใช่มย
แล้วก็พักไม่อยากกินอาหารที่โรงแรมเนี่ยู
ชิต้องเดินออกมาตอนเช้าอ่ะแล้วที่ถนนน่ะ
ก็จะมีรถเข็นเี่มาขายโจ๊กอขายข้าวที่แบบ
เลๆๆๆอ่ะแล้วก็มีใส่ไข่ใส่ปลาท่าโกงที่
โรงแรมไม่มีกินค่ะกลัวอใช่โรงแรมจะมี
เบรคฟาสใช่
มมีแบบไข่ไส้กรอกขนมปปังกาแฟสลัดอือแต่
กาแฟที่ฟุตบาดอ่ะเป็นกาแฟที่แบบมีถุงอ่ะ
แล้วใส่กาแฟแล้วก็มีน้ำแล้วก็ชงใส่ถ้วยมี
นมมีกาแฟแล้วก็คนๆกินกับปลาทองโก๋
อร่อยคือมันต้องได้บรรยากาศแบบนั้นไงใช่
และเด็กๆอ่ะถ้ามีเด็กๆไปด้วยก็หมูแบบไม่
ใช่อะไรเค้าเรียกอะไรนะไข่กระทะเหรอออเขา
จะเอามีเหมือนกับกระทะเล็กๆอ่ะนักเรียน
เป็นกระทะเล็กๆแล้วก็มีไข่อยากเอาไข่ 1
ฟองไข่ 2 ฟองอ่ะแล้วก็มีหมูสับใช่มั้ย
แล้วเด็กๆชอบกินไส้กรอกเค้าก็มีไส้กรอก
ห่ำนะอือเสร็จแล้วเก็ไปตั้งในเต่าที่ร้อน
ๆไข่ก็สุกหมูก็สุกไอก็สุกมาเป็นกระทะแบบ
ร้อนๆนะแล้วเราก็มีมีซอสซอสมะเขือเทศ
โอ้โหกับซีอิ๊วดักซีอิ๊วเนอะแล้วใส่แล้ว
ก็พริกไทยหน่อยนึงอออเด็กๆก็ชอบกินอันนี้
ก็ข้างทางมีใช่ค่ะอืคือถ้าเกิดนักท่อง
เที่ยวอ่ะหรือชาวต่างชาติมาประเทศไทยแล้ว
มาเจอบรรยากาศแบบเนี้ยมากินอาหารแบบเนี้ย
กลับไปประเทศเ้าไม่มีค่ะใช่ไม่มีมีแน่ๆ
เพราะฉะนั้นทำไมนักท่องเที่ยวที่มาประเทศ
ไทยจึงชอบอ่ะแล้วมันไม่แพงไงคุชิอื้อหือ
ของที่เข็นอยู่ข้างทางเนี่ยไม่แพง
อื้อหืออ้าอย่างเวลาเค้าบอกว่าเค้าไปกิน
แตงโมอ่ะคนญี่ปุ่นบอกแตงโมที่ญี่ปุ่น
เนี่ยชิ้นนึงเนี่ยถ้าตีเป็นแบบเงินไทยอ่ะ
50 บาทมากินที่ประเทศไทยชิ้นละ 20 บาท
ใหญ่กว่าอีกใหญ่กว่าอีกอีกใช่มเค้าก็รู้
สึกว่าโอโหแบบของประเทศไทยแล้วที่สำคัญ
ครูอ้อยนอกจากไม่แพงแล้วเนี่ยเวลาเรากิน
น่ะเา้าบอกว่าผลไม้ไทยน่ะมันอร่อยมีรส
หวานอ่าบางทีกินแตงโมประเทศไทยมันหวานไง
ไปกินแตงโมที่อื่นน่ะมันไม่หวานแบบนี้อ
ใช่แล้วมีผลไม้ประเทศไทยเนี่ยมีผลไม้เยอะ
มากชิใช่ผลไม้ตามฤดูกาลผลไม้เยอะมากแถม
เดินตามถนนเนี่ยมีร้านผลไม้ขายแบบเยอะอ่ะ
ถ้าคุณไม่ไม่ไม่ดูเป็นรถเข็นที่เป็นตู้
แล้วที่ทำสำเร็จอย่างครูชิบอกนะคุณเดินๆ
ไปคุณก็จะเจอกองเงาะ
ทุเรียนมะม่วงฝรั่งที่เป็นลูกๆอ่ะแล้วขาย
เป็นกิโลอ่ะมีเยอะใช่บางทีเเดินเข้าซอย
อ่ะแล้วก็มีบ้านคนใช่มยแล้ว้าข้างหน้า
บ้านน่ะเราเรียกว่าตึกแถวก็คือแบบเป็นตึก
ใช่มยแล้วแบ่งเป็นห้องห้องห้องแล้วข้าง
หน้าบ้านเนี่ยบางทีก็ขายของอ่ะบางบางที่
ก็มีหน้าบ้านเนี่ยเอาผลไม้มาวางกองแบบครู
อ้อยบอกไม่ต้องไปตลาดใช่ไม่ต้องไปถึงตลาด
ใช่อือเราไม่ต้องเข้าห้างสรรพสินค้าไม่
ต้องเข้าซุปเปอร์มาร์เก็ตนี่ข้างๆเลยเด
เดินตามถนน
อืมีเยอะแยะกูปุเอ่อูชิแล้วก็ไม่แพงถูก
มั้ยไม่แพงนะคะคือรถเข็นเนี่ยเอ่อนักท่อง
เที่ยวมาบอกโอ้แตงโมชิ้นละ 20 สับปะรด
ชิ้นละ 20 ถูกมากใช่
มยนักเรียนคะถ้าเกิดคุณเนี่ยซื้อที่เป็น
กิโลเอ่อกิโลอ่ะ 1 กก 2 กก 3 กกอ่ะใช่ม
ซื้อเป็นกิโลจะถูกมากกว่านี้อีก
อ่าใช่ไมใช่แตงโมลูกใหญ่ๆเ 80 บาทคุณหั่น
เป็น 10 ชิ้น
น่ะใช่มก็ได้กินแบบเยอะแยะอ่ะแล้วนัก
เรียนบอกโอ๊ยมันเยอะไปกินไม่หมดอ่ะไม่หมด
อก็เราก็มีตัวเลือกให้คุณไปซื้อตามรถเข็น
มีนะชิ้นเดียวคุณอยากกินวันนี้คุณไม่อยาก
กินแตงโมอย่างเดียวคุณอยากกินแตงโมฝรั่ง
มะม่วงแต่กินเยอะไม่ได้ไม่อร่อยต้องกิน
หลายๆอย่างกินเยอะแล้วมันเยอะไปก็ซื้อแตง
โมชิ้นนึงอ่าแล้วก็เอ่อมะม่วงซักเอ่อลูก
นึงพอเพราะลูกกิโลนึงก็หลายลูกเนาะฝรั่ง
สักลูกนึงน่ะได้ะ 3
อย่างเพื่อนูชิค่ะในที่ทำงานน่ะแล้วเ้า
แบบไปซื้อเเกินผลไม้เป็นประจำค่ะเพราะเขา
ไม่กินเนื้อสัตว์ไม่กินหมูไม่กินไก่ไม่
กินปลาไม่กินเนื้อสัตว์เลยที่มีชีวิตแล้ว
ก็ตายเนี่ยไม่าเอาผลไม้เอาผักแล้วก็กิน
แค่เนี้ยอยู่ได้แล้วอ่ะเออใช่อืเอ้อจริงๆ
ประเทศไทยก็มีหลายๆอย่างนะครูอ้อยที่ชาว
ต่างชาติเห็นแล้วก็อยากจะมีบ้างในประเทศ
เขาอ่าเราก็ได้ยินมาเนาะว่าญี่ปุ่นคน
ญี่ปุ่นอยากเออเราก็อยากได้ยินชาติอื่น
บ้างนะพชิว่าประเทศอื่นเี่อยากอยากมีอะไร
ที่เหมือนของประเทศไทย
อืเขียนมาบอกเราค่ะใช่ว่าคุณเป็นคนประเทศ
อะไรแล้วอยากให้ประเทศคุณมีอะไรเหมือน
ประเทศไทยบ้างเออคุณชอบอะไรในประเทศไทยอื
แต่วันเนี้ยหมดเวลาแล้วไงคะครูอ้อยก็ต้อง
ลานักเรียนไปก่อนนะคะแล้วโอกาสหน้าพบกัน
ใหม่ค่ะค่ะขอบคุณมากนะคะสวัสดีค่ะสวัสดี
ค่ะ